welcome to Stanford Graduate School of
Business follow our MSX students as they
take you on a 360 degree tour of student
and family residences we have a breadth
of on-campus housing options to fit your
family as well as your lifestyle our
first stop is Escondido village
primarily serving MSX MBA and other
graduate student families here's Carlos
who lives here with his wife Dora and
their three children
I'm animistic student by the Graduate
School of Business here at Stanford and
this is my house we live in Escondido we
touch which is five minutes our bike
right to the School of Business and
right now I'm taking my little one to
the daycare let's go Escondido village
houses more than 4000 graduate students
and their families with a vibrant
community of students partners and
children there are numerous nearby
playgrounds and on-campus daycare and
schooling options plus it's only a
10-minute walk to the business school
next follow way mean who lives in Munger
graduate residents Munger offers studios
and one two and four bedroom apartments
Munger houses 600 graduate students and
their partners across all disciplines
and graduate schools at Stanford it's
contemporary design emphasizes open
common areas community and
cross-disciplinary discussion we mean
lives in one of the two bedroom
apartments these furnished apartments
offer generous square footage private
bathrooms and full sized kitchens
without love of monger is that we have a
big community of students from many
different schools meeting here
we have all sorts of social activities
including p9 barbecue and my favorite
monger is a short seven minute walk to
the business school and it's never a bad
walk considering we have 261 days of
sunshine every year even closer are the
GSB residences they offer individual
rooms and kitchens shared by two rooms
meet Rob who lives at Jack McDonald Hall
which is part of GSB residences oh hey
there I'm Rob now a part of the MSX
program here in Jack McDonald Hall
this is a great place to live and it's
also great to be right across from the
GSB where you get to tap into the
wonderful MSX and broader GSB
communities anyway I got to run right
now and play some pool but I'll catch up
with you guys later all residences have
communal and social spaces for students
to unwind connect and organize
activities no matter where you live on
Stanford's campus you'll be part of a
vibrant community and form strong
friendships that will last a lifetime